Jenny hold up,
look I brought a disc
and we could copy this.
Okay, no problem.
All we gotta do is--
Whoa.
|| Don't copy, don't copy that fluffy
|| Feel it, feel it
what's that what's that
|| Is that really what
you want, your life to go
But they can't stop people
from copying it's too easy.
It's might be easy but
it's still against the law.
|| Don't copy, don't copy that fluffy
Around the mid two thousands post Napster,
music piracy was still a huge problem.
At the time it was all towards.
Everybody had moved to Torrance
that's how most people
were sort of young people
at least were getting their music.
Online piracy is costing
the US film industry,
$20 billion a year.
Like don't they know they can
download this stuff for free?
Use BitTorrent.
The question is what's the
best way to find the RIAA.
How could 98% shame on you people.
The music industry was preoccupied
with the whole peer-to-peer
file transfer, illegal theft.
It had to figure out how
it was going to attack
and approach the marketplace
in this new world
to be able to remain
viable and competitive.
To us is black and white
and you pay for it.
You go straight up and
down and it's stilling.
Sweden out of all the
countries in the world,
had adopted pirate technology
more than anywhere else.
It was a country full of hackers.
They'd come up with all
different kind of takes
on peer to peer networks and bit torrents
and they had the pirate party.
The entire political party
that really traces its roots
back to Napster.
For them trading music it's
like a political cultural calling.
The Swedish parts of the music industry
they were suffering even more
than maybe their American counterparts.
Very few people were buying CDs anymore
or very few people were buying
licensed material online.
Everyone was using the
file sharing networks.
At that time there was
a guy named Daniel Ark
who was Swedish
who had previously been
the CEO of a Torin company.
And he said, I have a plan
to make people pay for music again.
We're going to move beyond
the locally stored MP3 file
into the kind of like
globally distributed stream.
That was his business model,
which he calls Spotify.
What if instead of you know having to go
through the trouble of you know buying
and downloading music but
don't think he had access
to all the music in the world.
Just through a streaming service.
Spotify launched in
Sweden in October 2008.
Spotify took off in Sweden
and so act was able to go around
to different countries
and get and get the labels
there to do the same thing and
eventually he came to the US.
Danielle's he's not Steve Jobs.
Is very soft-spoken.
You can tell that he's kind
of a nerdy engineer, is very polite
and easygoing and for the labels.
I think Daniel being not
as abrasive and scary
and powerful as Steve Jobs was
probably pretty attractive.
And the thought of him sitting
in a room with all these
music exacts and, and Bay
his fist on the table is
hard for me to imagine.
He's the one who talks all of
these labels into cooperating
and giving the service
that he made a chance.
Spotify, represented us with an option.
Now, if you say we don't want to use it,
we don't want to distribute that way
but we'll be like dinosaurs
and we wouldn't be here.
The mistakes the major record labels made
in the late nineties I will
give them credit for this.
They learn from those
mistakes and they understood
that they had to scramble to get ahead
of the next wave of technology.
Europe's best kept secret
is out in the open.
Spotify has landed in the USA.
And with 10 million
registered users in Europe
it could be a big hit here.
But it service is ad free
but locked your computer
while they're premium
service brings Spotify
to your mobile devices.
You're like, Hey, you want
to hear this new song.
All you have to do is go
boom, it's right there.
Wait a minute, everything's
here like everything?
Just like the first time he
used an MP3 I said, Oh my God
I'm never going to pay again.
The first time I use Spotify
I was like I'm going to pay again alright.
And so that's how well it worked.
From about the turn
of the century until
three or four years ago
the music industry had lost
around 40% of its entire value.
Physical sales are pretty much over
but streaming is growing
and growing and growing.
Next thing you know, Google,
Amazon, Microsoft, Apple
they all want to have a
streaming subscription service.
Good Morning, today we're
announcing Apple Music.
Today I'm happy to announce
Google Play Music all access.
Amazon is taking the plunge,
diving into an already
crowded streaming market
with a new subscription music service.
Some big names behind a
streaming music service
being relaunched now
with some help from Jay-Z
he bought tidal for
$56 million in January.
We've reached a point
where there are too many
streaming options to mention.
Companies ran away from music
because there wasn't any growth
now there is, that's a sign
that the industry is becoming healthy
you know after years of being really sick.
It's just a question of
what it means for artists.
For Microsoft, Google
Apple, music doesn't mean
something special to them.
It's just something
that gets bundled along
in this monthly fee that
you pay for various things
whereas obviously this is
the lifeblood for musicians.
Streaming has a lot of business
challenges attached to it.
The whole notion of micro pennies.
You could have hundreds
Of thousands of streams
and you get paid 12 cents.
People can't even tell me
what a stream is worth.
This changes from month to month
to month to month to month.
No one knows how to quantify.
As far as online streaming,
the record companies
they take whatever their percentage is.
Everyone gets a cut.
What's left of that we
have to split four ways
and with our managers
so it's literally nothing you know.
The artists are looking
at these 10th of a cent
royalties and going that's crazy.
Do you know how many times
I'm going to have to listen
to that song or those groups
of songs to be equivalent
to what I'd make from an album sale?
Tonight word of music SmackDown,
Taylor Swift is pulling her music
off of Spotify and all
of this overpricing.
In an editorial she wrote file sharing
and streaming have shrunk the numbers
of paid album sales drastically,
valuable things should be paid for.
That's all like what Taylor Swift just did
and I think that's awesome.
I mean, the only person
really getting screwed here
as the artist and that's
the way it always is.
Why don't they pay Taylor Swift more?
Why don't they pay you
already the rugged man wall.
Taylor don't need the money as much as me
but she's got a good point.
Everybody's doing the work
then they need to get
paid, just that simple.
I need my money.
So you had some artists speaking out?
We're released a new single last week.
She's one of the partners of title
you can't stream it on Spotify
but you can stream it
exclusively on tidal.
Well, in reality, they're all coming back.
The other week Taylor Swift
decided to once again offer
her entire back catalog on Spotify.
With streaming,
it's the way that the
music industry is going
so we're all gonna have to
figure out a way to make it work.
Well, people are beeching
they not making enough money.
They have to understand if you
you're a successful artists
today, you can make more
money than you've ever made
in the history of the music business.
There are sponsorships and you can do ads.
In addition, concert revenues
exceed by a huge margin
which used to, so you have to
look at all the opportunities
not only from these streaming services.
Yeah, you get pennies on the
dollar whatever, who cares
go out there and play
a show and make money
and get out there and do that.
Don't complain about an
internet streaming service
that's so lame, cry me a river.
Through this entire period
of time, while the recorded
music industry has been down
the live music industry has been flushing
and there's maybe an easy
explanation in a world
where we get less and
less personal online.
The precious thing is
seeing it live experience
cause you can't digitize experience.
The digital age makes it a
lot easier to scout talent
I would say.
We're able to get data
and metrics from all
sorts of different sites
whether that's Spotify listener data
on the publicly available
about the artist page.
There's usually about 40% we
see of their monthly listeners
in a certain city would
actually purchase tickets
to that show in that city.
I think now you're
recording is advertisement
for your performance
and your live engagement
not the other way around.
Touring, touring is
nonstop revenue all year.
That's where all the money comes from.
I'll talk till I'm dead.
It shouldn't be that you
have to be a touring act.
Touring is grueling.
We don't want to tour all the time.
You know, it's, we're getting older
and it's a lot of hard work
being out there doing that.
But those are the things you have to do.
I think I make the most money
the majority of my money from shows
it wasn't always like that
but it's like that now.
March is probably next.
I didn't think I'd be a T-shirt merchant.
What? I never started making music.
These are SOPs.
These go really quickly
especially in shows.
This is a raincoat, it
has the hot sugar castle.
I have shirts, I have Afro Hoodies,
I have this Apple-Shirt right here.
This is a T-shirt, another T-shirt
with another picture of me.
You cannot, to my
knowledge download a shirt.
This is a front and back hat.
This is Baha'u'llah Java.
It's a brand of coffee
that Zakk Wylde created.
I'm telling you, you can clean your house.
About five times mowed
the lawn three times
even though it's already
finished the first time
you mow it and that's before brunch.
And it is one of the best
selling coffees on Amazon.
You have to, as an artist make
products that are sellable.
Because music not as
sellable as it used to be.
Where records had always
been by far the majority
of the income earned by
people who made albums.
Increasingly artists were
making more money from touring
from live events and ticketing
and merchandising and wheels
and they really were
earning from their records.
Our revenue model didn't
make any sense any longer.
I was offered really deals in my life.
|| How is my label, my
hussle that's my label
And it got to the point
where I hated my label.
So I said, Hey, I'm going
to run and do this myself.
And when I started doing
independent records
that's when all my
money started coming in.
And that's where all my
success started coming in
and that's where all of
my fans started coming in.
Cheers to rappers gone
from making mix tapes
in his South side Chicago
home to winning three Grammys
and performing for the
president at the white house.
All without the backing
of a single record label.
Move artists have been
making more music at home
and releasing it themselves
in industry and services.
So it's a, it's been
creative release songs.
We're now going to be rolling
out the ability to monetize
directly on SoundCloud.
We're inviting hundreds
of thousands of creators.
This means more money in their pocket.
At the end of the day on
a revenue share basis.
Thousands of people are making money
off their talents and
hobbies with Patreon.
Patreon it's like
Kickstarter but it's ongoing.
It's per music video I upload.
Bandcamp is this website where artists
can independently just take
the music that they produce
themselves and put it up onto the website.
And artist stuff
was there music to Bandcamp,
a fan pays directly for it.
We take a small cut It's about
half of what iTunes charges.
Bandcamp has become the hero.
I think that they are more closely attuned
to listening to the needs of musicians
and actually meeting those
concrete needs better
than I think virtually any
other company that's out there.
They've really provided
an online record store
and a way for artists to recoup money
and I haven't seen any other company
try to meet those needs.
If you've got merchandise,
if you've got physical CDs,
if you've got T-shirts and hats
and all sorts of stuff like that
you can sell that directly on
the Bandcamp platform as well.
Can't do that on Spotify or Apple music.
That was another grim milestone.
The world surpassing 1 million
deaths from the coronavirus.
I don't think we were
prepared for the realization
that the majority of our
livelihood depended on us being
on the road all the time and
physically being at shows.
Most artists today or successful
are making the majority
of their income through live performance.
60, 70, sometimes upwards of 80%
of an artist's income
is reliant on touring
on merchandise on, on
this, which is empty.
A little more than a month
before they're scheduled
to be in California, riot
reports BTS canceled shows
in South Korea due to fear
over the spread of the virus.
More than 40% of Canadians
wouldn't feel comfortable going
to a music event until at least six months
after social restrictions are lifted.
The shutdown of live shows
this year has affected me
in so many different ways.
I have been turning to live streaming I'm
on Twitch every week.
I've built up a nice little community.
I've got a discord going,
I'm doing the whole thing.
Let go, let go.
Look, we got to get it bracket in this.
You just do it for the
latest channel on Swiss.
In a major collaboration
that's clearly a sign of times,
12 million players locked
into fortnite last night
to watch a virtual Travis
Scott perform in concert.
|| This day is a nice and with a no both
|| At the gate outside when they pull up
|| Basically means it was good
It's great for the artists
it's great for the fans.
And that's something I think
that you're going to see
more of after the pandemic
because people not
wanting to just see a show
at a venue in a theater,
and you'll want to see more
and more experiences and less
and less just pure concerts.
Everybody on YouTube subscribe.
Which you subscribe, Facebook
do you like it to subscribe too, let's go.
Make sure you subscribe
make sure you smash the
subscribe button on YouTube.
Thank you guys for donating.
Even if you didn't have
the means to donate
thank you for tuning in.
I've had a music career
just by going straight
to consumers into an audience
and fans rather than waiting
for this faceless music
industry guy to help pitch it.
You didn't do nothing,
I did all the hard work.
So why shouldn't I make a
hundred percent of that money?
What's up guys.
Hi guys, welcome back to the channel.
Zoom in I want to see you.
I got my screen right up here.
I watch you guys interaction
is everything for me.
Something that's really
unique with live streaming
is that you actually get to
know the names of your fans
and you get to know their,
their personal lives.
Big hearts up for big cheese right now.
Cause he needs our love man.
He was, he was down for a little second.
Dude, shout out Savannah Bebo
Sparky, miss winter Falcon
you guys are legends, legends.
Your fans get actually chat with you live
and give input as far as
what they want to hear.
So the revolution will
be televised actually.
But there really is
nothing like being on stage
with tens of thousands
of people in front of you
at a festival with the lights
and everybody's screaming.
I just miss it all.
I don't think streaming
is the end of the game.
I think the game will continue to unfold.
You as a
as a talented artist you can
go pick your own recording.
You can build your
career using social media
and the major labels role in
creating the next generation
of successful artists will
become less and less important.
We found out that the record
companies are limited,
cycle okay you taken
but what you given back,
you've given me a piece
of my soul back to me
or you just taking my soul and
keeping it and cashing it in.
If you've only got a niche audience
it doesn't make sense
to sign to a major label
Right now, more than ever the
law of a thousand true fans
is what we're going to see
working as a model going forward.
You could have 10 million
plays on your song on Spotify,
but that doesn't mean
that you're going to sell
a hundred tickets for a show.
1000 true fans can sustain you
if you have the right platforms in place.
And that can be anything
from BandCamp to Patreon
to Twitch.
Any of these places that
are meant to build community
and allow you to have a
space that you control
where you can sell virtually anything
about your creative process that you want.
Most people who aren't on
a major label want to be.
A lot of the DIY guys once they start
to kind of you know, blow
up, they go to the label.
The weekend is a perfect example.
Can you did these kind of
brilliant albums in his bedroom?
They got massive radio play
after he gave them away
for free, but then he
went to the major label
when the time came.
Labels definitely have a place
but they're not the gatekeepers anymore.
You don't have to sign
to a major record label
to be successful in the
music business anymore.
You know, and thank God for that.
Stand clear of the closing doors, please.
The MP3 is now an obsolete technology.
By 1998 there were more
sophisticated replacements available.
But the core of what it did lives on.
Whenever you're streaming
music via your phone,
it's using the same techniques
that Brandenburg pioneered
back in the eighties.
People are walking around
with their internet connected phones
and they're just listening
to music all the time
and it couldn't be easier.
So finally, we have this thing
that everybody's been talking
about literally for, you know, 20 years
the Celestial Jukebox.
And people are listening to more music
than they ever have in history.
If you go to the roots of the
mobile computing revolution,
it's based on MP3 piracy.
The idea of walking into an Apple Store
and spending three or $400 on a gadget
that you had to get primed by
the MP3 to want to do that.
Ultimately I think the
MP3 created more value
than it destroyed.
Yesterday Apple reported
the largest quarterly profit
of any public company in history.
A lot of money was made
along the way, just not
by the people who used to make it.
The fundamental way that
companies make money
has completely changed.
The first time an MP3 was moved
from one person to the next.
Generations from that point
forward have realized access
to things is more
valuable than owning them.
Why own a car when I
can call Uber anytime?
Why own a second home
when I can go to Airbnb?
If I can have access and
hear any song when I want,
why own a CD?
The much of technology is a
good thing, not a bad thing.
The fact that it uniquely affected us
was the way of life really.
Nowadays I love to listen
to classical music.
I love some of the newer music.
What about rap music?
Oh yeah why not?
Talking about MP3
I had the feeling, this is not
good for the music industry.
But in the end, I think
it changed for the better.